[Musik]
blumen für wahlsieger olaf scholz genau
1,6 prozentpunkte liegt seine spd vor
der union er sieht darin einen klaren
regierungsauftrag für sich armin laschet
selbst wahlverlierer widerspricht keine
partei habe einen regierungsauftrag
bekommen bei einem von beiden werden
grüne und fdp wohl ins kanzleramt
verhelfen es ist tag eins nach der wahl
und tag eins bei der suche nach einer
neuen regierung
guten abend hinein willkommen bei uns
eine politische ereignisreichen tag aber
auch sport haben wir in der sendung
versprochen mit katja stresow
viel los heute in berlin vor und hinter
den kulissen da werden bündnisse
geschmiedet positionen abgesteckt und es
gibt auch einiges aufzuarbeiten basis
für all das ist der wilde willen der
wählerinnen und wähler in deutschland
gucken wir also auf das vorläufige
amtliche endergebnis dieser
bundestagswahl die spd gewinnt erheblich
dazu und liegt vorn mit
25,7 prozent die union stürzt ab auf ein
historisch schlechtes ergebnis von
24,1 platz drei für die grünen mit
starken gewinnen auf 14,8 die fdp
verbessert sich leicht auf 11,5 die afg
fällt zurück auf den fünften platz mit
jetzt 10,3 prozent und die linke schafft
gerade mal 4,9 prozent bleibt aber
trotzdem im bundestag dank drei
direktmandaten und wer wird kanzler die
frage bleibt noch offen denn die
absolute mehrheit von
368 der 735 sitze erreicht keine der
parteien
rein rechnerisch würde es wieder für
eine große koalition reichen die aber
weder spd noch union wollen deshalb ist
ein dreierbündnis wahrscheinlicher
entweder spd mit grünen und fdp oder die
union mit grünen und fdp
cdu/csu versuchen heute das kunststück
eine regierungsoption zu obwohl sie
dramatisch verloren haben und mit
erheblicher unruhe kämpfen im eigenen
lager daniel jonsson hat mehr es wartete
die bekannte wort wolke heute durch die
parteizentrale schonungslose analyse
persönliche verantwortung ein bisschen
zumindest und das zauberwort demut die
jedoch forderte armin laschet in
zugleich von der spd ein
vorwärtsverteidigung
das ist ein moment wo gerade die beiden
großen volksparteien die den an freilich
haben müssten um die 30 prozent zu
liegen mit demut vor den wähler treten
müssen eben jene demut forderte
allerdings auch die partei von ihrem
erfolglosen kandidaten selbst ein nicht
wörtlich aber deutlich wir haben ein
ergebnis erzielt das ich mir vor wenigen
monaten noch nicht einmal in den
schlimmsten alpträumen vorstellen konnte
und deshalb werden wir jetzt hinter
verschlossenen türen über die
notwendigen maßnahmen zur neuaufstellung
der cdu inhaltlich und auch in jeder
anderen hinsichten sprechen vielleicht
auch deshalb klang lasche defensiver als
gestern sprach nur noch von einem
regierungsangebot fischer maika das
nennen sie hier zukunfts koalition
während er um seine eigene zukunft
kämpft inklusive kräftemessen mit
fraktionschef brinkhaus der auf seine
wiederwahl morgen beharrte vor möglichen
sondierungsgesprächen das werden wir bis
morgen klären in welcher form wir diese
abstimmung machen mir ist wichtig dass
der ralph brinkhaus dabei ist und für
die fraktion an diesen gesprächen
teilnehmen besonders groß ist das
entsetzen im osten in sachsen und
thüringen wurde die afg stärkste kraft
die cdu dritte ich will dass dieses
ergebnis ein wirkliches saß dafür die
union in deutschland ist und das erste
was man sagen muss ist genau das und die
grundhaltung dass wir weitermachen wie
bisher muss ins verderben führen
deswegen braucht es jetzt erst einmal
einen innehalten konstant indes das
schwierige verhältnis zur csu alle
trügen verantwortung so markus söder
heute samt im innkreis jahr noch bei uns
gab es die ein andere personalfrage die
den einer den wähler verunsichert hat
aus meiner sicht einer der unnötigsten
niederlagen der vergangenen jahrzehnten
für jamaika stehe dennoch auch die csu
bereit und weil das eigene wahlergebnis
zwar auch historisch schlecht war aber
nicht so schlecht wie das der cdu habe
man künftig mehr mitzubestimmen ja wir
sind um 1 kleiner geworden als csu
landesgruppe aber in der gemeinsamen
fraktion größer die nächste koalition
müsse eine sein die mit freude regiere
betonte laschet heute es scheint ein aus
unionssicht hochgestecktes ziel
theo guten abend was passiert da heute
innerhalb der union wie sicher kann sich
armin laschet halten nachdem er aus
unions sicht katastrophal verloren hat
heute nachmittag gab es jedenfalls schon
die erste rücktrittsforderung von der
stellvertretenden cdu
fraktionsvorsitzenden in rheinland pfalz
war dazu muss man wissen dass die
landtagsabgeordnete chefstrategen von
norbert röttgen war der wiederum im
kandidaten machtkampf schüler
unterstützt hat also noch sind die
massiven kritiker vor allem unionisten
die lage kritisch sehen aber die stimmen
werden lauter offensichtlich sind über
nacht schockwellen durch die partei
gelaufen und deshalb ist jetzt mit blick
auf eine regierungsbildung nur noch von
angebot statt von anspruch die rede und
diese angebotene jamaika option ist dann
auch zugleich ein teil des schutzschirms
von armin laschet denn kaum jemand in
der union will schuld daran sein dass
diese mit laschet und ja seiner nähe zu
lindner verbundene jamaica möglichkeit
dann wegfällt also morgen übrigens
könnten sich in der fraktion schon
wichtige machtstrukturen zeigen denn
ralph brinkhaus möchte in dieser
einflussreichen position wiedergewählt
werden laschet aber will ihnen nur
vorübergehend verlängern vielleicht ja
mit dem blick auf einen späteren eigenen
anspruch also es geht in diesen tagen um
die macht im land aber auch um die in
der union theo koll zdf berlin
dankeschön und dann gucken wir jetzt in
der sendung zum wahlsieger spd die zwar
deutlich dazugewonnen hat aber nur knapp
vor der union landete und jetzt
ebenfalls versucht ein dreierbündnis auf
die beine zu stellen kanzlerkandidat
olaf scholz spricht heute von genügend
schnittmengen fdp und grünen andreas
künast beobachtet dass für uns
es ist ein wink mit dem blumenstrauß und
olaf scholz will sichergehen dass man
ihn versteht rot gelb grün rote blume
gelbe blume grünes naja blattwerk es ist
das bild zur botschaft zu scholz
wichtigste botschaft am tag nach der
bundestagswahl
sie hat drei parteien gestärkt die
sozialdemokratische partei die grünen
und die fdp und deshalb ist das der
sichtbare auftrag den die bürger noch
bürger dieses landes formuliert haben
diese drei sollen auch die nächste
regierung führen dass mit der union die
zweitplatzierten geben falls die
regierung führen wollen prangert scholz
nicht im grundsätzlichen an willy brandt
tat es auch aber im konkreten
cdu und csu haben nicht nur erheblich an
stimmen verloren sondern sie haben
tatsächlich auch die botschafter bürgern
und bürger bekommen sie sollen jetzt
nicht mehr in der regierung sein sondern
in die opposition gehen im
parteivorstand lodern noch einmal
erleichterung hoffnung triumph auf nach
19 jahren verhandelt die spd wieder über
eine kanzlerschaft ein sechsköpfiges
sondierungsteam soll grünen und fdp
jetzt erstmal verlockende angebote
machen und jetzt erst mal keine
bedingungen stellen deswegen finde ich
das von allen seiten rote linien die
über die medien dem anderen zugespielt
werden ein kleines fenster schließen
dass wir eine gemeinsame grundlage
wichtig wäre auf olaf scholz kommen seit
vergangener nacht nicht mehr nur die
deutschen erwartungen zu fragen zur
außenpolitik fragen auf englisch
prasseln heute auf den vielleicht
bundeskanzler ein der eine deutsche
regierung bis weihnachten in aussicht
stellt bibi christmas is possible keine
antwort gibt stolz auf die frage nach
einem mitgliederentscheid mit dem
parteivize kevin kühnert die neue
koalition absegnen lassen will klare
antwort dagegen zur ersten
personalentscheidung rolf mützenich soll
fraktionsvorsitzender bleiben
und dann kommen wir zu denen die zwar
nicht die stärksten parteien geworden
sind aber von denen jetzt alles abhängt
sollte am ende erstmals seit den 50er
jahren ein dreierbündnis die regierung
bilden dann führt an fdp und grünen kein
weg vorbei entsprechend selbstbewusst
sind sie heute aufgetreten britta
spiekermann
als robert habeck heute morgen um kurz
vor sieben beachtet da hat er schon
zwölf sms auf dem handy er erzählt es
nicht ohne stolz sprüht vor
selbstbewusstsein will habe jetzt den
ersten platz telefoniert hat er gestern
mit christian lindner das ist bekannt
wie steht es um die grüne doppelspitze
wer nach dem misslungenen berbalk
wahlkampf heute trennendes witterte der
sollte nachdrücklich vom gegenteil
überzeugt werden das persönliche
verhältnis ist gut stabil im takt und
vertrauensvoll war uns sind die fragen
geklärt aber wir sind jetzt einfach nach
einer bundestagswahl wir fangen jetzt an
sondierung zu führen gemeinsam im team
als parteivorsitzende gemeinsam mit
einem sondierungsteam was wir die
nächsten tage verkünden werden und alle
weiteren personalfragen kommen dann zu
ihrer zeit erste gespräche solle es mit
der fdp geben zeitnah heißt es mittwoch
wahrscheinlich habeck bringt jamaika
erfahrung aus schleswig holstein mit
allerdings die erste wahl der grünen ist
ein dreier bündnis unter führung der spd
mit blick auf die letzten stunden wo die
union ja gerade selber dabei ist sich
aus der regierungsfähigkeit ein stück
weit zu verabschieden gibt es eine
gewisse logik die gespräche mit spd und
fdp
jetzt zu führen das heißt aber nicht
dass wir mit der union nicht reden
werden die fdp die zweiten königs
kanzler macher die liberalen hatten
schon vor der wahl die preise in die
höhe getrieben keine steuererhöhungen
kein aufweichen der schuldenbremse wenig
spielraum für ein gemeinsames spiel
zwischen grünen und fdp gibt es die
größten inhaltlichen
unterschiede bei den parteien des
demokratischen zentrums die jetzt über
eine regierungsbildung miteinander
sprechen könnten deshalb macht es sinn
angesichts dieser bisweilen bestehenden
polarisierung den gemeinsamen grund zu
suchen
vor anderthalb stunden wurde lindner
erneut zum fraktionsvorsitzenden gewählt
ein klares verhandlungsmandat lindner
will mehr in einer neuen regierung
bundesfinanzminister werden das will
robert habeck aber auch
unterlag guten amt das ist ja hoch
interessant was die sogenannten kleinen
daten quasi selbsttätig ausloten wer
unter ihnen kanzler werden könnte wie
hat man sich das denn konkret hinter den
kulissen vorzustellen im moment
also eigentlich reden ja alle parteien
miteinander bei auf informellen kanälen
das sprechen dann nicht nur die
parteivorsitzenden miteinander sondern
zum beispiel auch bundestagsabgeordnete
die sich gut kennen und die dann schon
mal ausloten was geht und was nicht neu
ist jetzt eben dass fdp und grüne schon
einmal miteinander reden wollen und das
interessant zu sehen welches
unterschiedliche gewicht sie da rein
bringen wollen christian lindner hat er
heute vom fdp-vorstand den offiziellen
auftrag zuvor sondierungen bekommen das
hat natürlich schon ein größeres gewicht
und die grünen sind da sehr
zurückhaltend haben sprechen immer noch
von gesprächen in kleinstem kreis hängen
das ganze also etwas tiefer vielleicht
auch deshalb weil sie viele
schwierigkeiten sehen das hat robert
habeck heute schon einmal gesagt dass
werden keine leichten verhandlungen und
er hat auch darauf hingewiesen das ist
dieses mal sehr darauf ankommt dass bei
solchen gesprächen auch bei den
informellen nicht zuviel nach außen
dringt denn auch daran seien die jamaika
verhandlungen beim letzten mal
gescheitert live aus berlin und aller
banerjee vielen dank bei der afg heute
streit auf offener bühne 10,3 prozent
für die afd das ist deutlich weniger als
vor vier jahren parteichef jörg menten
wirft dem spitzenduo alice weidl kino
copala fehler vor und verlangt eine
gründliche wahlanalyse da verschärft
sich die schwelende auseinandersetzung
um die richtung der partei david gepaart
mit
leuten ist genervt minutenlangen lässt
man ihn wach
eine frostige begrüßung zwischen
parteichef und spitzenkandidaten unten
vor dem pressesaal die luft zum
schneiden oben darin
am tag nach der wahl zelebriert die afb
den spalt und streitet auf offener bühne
über die auslegung des eigenen
ergebnisses ich muss dann auch ganz klar
sagen dass ich das ergebnis bin ich und
uns auch nicht schlecht reden lassen
lasse von niemandem denn wir haben nun
mal ein solides ergebnis gefahren wir
mögen ja wirklich eine differenz haben
wenn der in der beurteilung wenn wir 20
prozent unserer wählerstimmen verlieren
oder fast 20 prozent dann halte ich
zufriedenheit für unangebracht es ist
zusammen mit den landtagswahlen gestern
die siebte wahl mit verlusten für die
afg in serie ein negativtrend während
die partei bei der bundestagswahl im
westen einbüßt gewinnt sie im osten 16
direktmandate 10 allein in sachsen wie
hier in görlitz mich haben meine
ergebnisse auch niedersachsen doch mit
großer demut berührt insgesamt gerührt
und nochmal wir müssen vielleicht auch
mal schauen dass es eben diese
regionalen unterschiede gibt wahlen
werden im westen gewonnen weil dort
einfach die wähler zahlen viel viel
höher sind und da waren wir nicht
erfolgreich noch mal wir haben nirgendwo
die zehn prozent grenze im westen
überschritten trotz der verluste wollen
sich weiter und kuba am mittwoch als
fraktionsvorsitzende wählen lassen
zusammen als doppelpack so ein
wahlverfahren findet heute noch sei
keine gute praxis
und dann die linke wie schon gehört nur
4,9 prozent der stimmen deshalb kommt
sie diesmal nur durch die hintertür in
den bundestag es sind drei direktmandate
in berlin und leipzig die der partei am
ende 39 sitze bescheren durch das
schwache abschneiden der linken ist rot
grün rot rechnerisch ausgeschlossen
spitzenkandidatin janine wissler sprach
angesichts der verluste von einem
schweren schlag und erklärte die partei
müsse jetzt neu aufgestellt werden
weitere analysen rund um die wahl gleich
nach uns in einem zdf spezial und in der
zdf- heute- app haben wir
zusammengestellt welche prominenten
politiker mit ihrer direktkandidatur
gescheitert sind und sie können
nachschauen wie in ihrem wahlkreis
abgestimmt wurde in der berliner
landespolitik sieht alles nach einer
regierungsbildung unter führung der spd
aus mit 21,4 prozent liegt
spitzenkandidatin franziska gefahr hier
vorn allerdings mit dem schlechtesten
nachkriegsergebnis für die
sozialdemokraten hier bieten sich jetzt
gleich vier potenzielle
regierungspartner an
aufzuklären ist auch noch wie es
passieren konnte dass der wahltag in
berlin gestern begleitet war von einer
ganzen serie von pannen stephan
merseburger
lange schlangen fehlende oder falsche
wahlzettel zu wenige kabinen bundestag
abgeordnetenhaus bezirksversammlung
volksentscheid die berliner mussten
gestern insgesamt sechs kreuze machen
das brauchte zeit es herrschte
stellenweise chaos berlin hat ein
klägliches bild abgegeben heute kritik
an der landeswahlleiterin muss die wahl
etwa wiederholt werden
also eine wahlwiederholung muss
angesetzt werden wenn es eben
mandatsrelevanten wahlfehler
gab und ob es diese gab kann ich ihnen
heute noch nicht sagen mandatsrelevanten
fehler verändern das wahlergebnis die
verteilung der sitze im abgeordnetenhaus
etwa ob es zu solchen fehlern gekommen
ist muss noch untersucht werden klar
dagegen ist der brisante volksentscheid
deutsche wohnen & co enteignen hatte
erfolg
eine herausforderung für die
sozialdemokraten franziska giffey sie
verteidigt das rathaus erstmals bekommt
die stadt eine regierende
bürgermeisterin defy ist strikt gegen
enteignung
wir müssen als politik damit
verantwortungsvoll und respektvoll
umgehen ich finde es muss eine sehr
ernsthafte prüfung geben über
rechtmäßigkeit verfassungsmäßigkeit
finanzierbarkeit und die folgen die das
für das land berlin auch hat gefehlt
zuerst sondierungsgespräche mit grünen
und linken dann mit cdu und fdp führen
die entscheidungsfrage wird bei der
regierungsbildung eine der zentralen
punkte seien
und so fiel zunächst zu den wahlen ein
starkes erdbeben hat heute morgen die
griechische insel kreta erschüttert
mindestens ein mensch kam ums leben
mehrere wurden verletzt die feuerwehr
musste menschen aus den trümmern
befreien vor allem alte steinhäuser
stürzten ein wie das dach dieser kirche
im zentrum der insel auch neuere gebäude
wurden zum teil schwer beschädigt jetzt
sollen spürhunde vom festland eingesetzt
werden um unter den schutthaufen nach
weiteren opfern zu suchen
das war man schnitt in der sendung und
gegenüber zum sport mit katja
fußball-champions-league woche und
morgen muss der bvb bei portugals
meister sporting lissabon ran und dabei
wie schon bei der niederlage am samstag
gegen gladbach auf torjäger erling
holland verzichten der kämpft weiter mit
muskulären problemen
trainer marco rose macht den borussen
fans in der hna frage wenig hoffnung bei
harlingen da tust dann doch noch richtig
weg vielleicht hat er richtig gut
geschlafen gut gegessen
gut regeneriert und es geht dann doch
schneller auch der einsatz von marco
reus der am knie angeschlagen ist bleibt
fraglich julian brand scheint dagegen
wieder einsatzbereit rose warnt vor
portugals meister trotz der 1 zu 5
auftaktniederlage gegen amsterdam gibt
aber als ziel drei punkte aus klares
signal an die an die gruppe zu senden
und wieder in die erfolgsspur
zurückzukommen hoffnungen macht die
makellose heimbilanz im europapokal
gegen portugiesische klubs sechs siege
in sechs spielen
europa gegen nordamerika im tennis und
das europäische team die
titelverteidigung in boston geschafft
deutlich ging der sieg mit 14 zu eins an
die europäer auch dank alexander zverev
alexander zverev und andré rudolph
ziehen den schlussstrich unter einen
überragenden auftritt europas gegen den
rest der welt den ersten satz gewinnen
sie deutlich mit 6 zu 2 spannung kommt
dann im zweiten auf frei leo parker usa
und der kanadier denis schapowalow
aufspielen herrliches doppel tennis
76 satzausgleich
es wäre von true blood die freunde aus
kindertagen finden den match-tie-break
zu ihren stärken zurück 10 zu 3 der
vierte sieg nacheinander für europa im
later cup
fünfte chance nächstes jahr in london
danke katja sohn schauen aufs wetter da
ist regen angesagt aber morgen wird es
ruhiger verspricht gleich osten telli
ich empfehle ich natürlich das heute
journal um 21.45 die kollegin marietta
slomka hat fragen an den grünen co
vorsitzenden robert habeck jetzt gleich
nach uns wie gesagt das zdf spezial team
heute 19 und sagt danke und gern bis
morgen ich wünsche ihnen allen ein sehr
angenehmer
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter hinter dem blau was sie hier
sehen was den regen darstellen soll da
liegt eine kaltfront und die zieht
relativ rasch nach osten und dahinter
lockert es auf vorübergehend setzt sich
hier hoher luftdruck durch ja in der
nacht wird diese kaltfront aber quer
über deutschland liegen und sich
allmählich ostwärts verlagern ganz im
norden richtung ostsee da löst ja auch
einige gewitter aus ganz im westen wird
es ruhiger und es bildet sich nebel aber
im südwesten ist auch etwas regen dabei
temperaturen sinken nach westen hin auf
sechs bis neun grad gespürt waren also
das kühlere luft herein geflossen ist
deutlich mildern vor der kaltfront nach
osten hin bei 14 grad morgen land zieht
der regen im osten allmählich ab
ansonsten gibt's sonst ein an der
nordsee oder richtung oberrhein
dazwischen viele wolken aber auch mal
sonnenschein bei höchsten temperaturen
bis 21 grad im südwesten und zum
beispiel 17 grad im osten deutschlands
die kommenden tage werden ruppiger
zumindest am mittwoch da kommt ziemlich
viel wind im norden auf und schaue bei
14 bis 20 grad und in der nacht auf
donnerstag wird es dann vor allem im
norden sturm geben richtung nordsee und
damit ein schöner abend